foreign
daily cancellation I must come to the
defense of a fellow YouTuber and
commentator Sydney Watson was the
subject of Internet outrage over the
weekend it generated critical critical
headlines in the media after she
complained about her experience on an
American Airlines flight where she was
stuck for several hours between two
morbidly obese passengers now it all
began with this tweet thread published
in helpless anguish a few days ago in
which Watson writes quote I am currently
literally wedged between two obese
people on my flight this is absolutely
not acceptable or okay if if fat people
want to be fat fine but it's something
else entirely when I'm stuck between you
with your arm rolls on my body for three
hours
she continues I don't care if this is
mean my entire body is currently being
touched against my wishes I can't even
put the armrest down on either side
because there's no effing room I'm sick
of acting like fatness to this extent is
normal let me assure you it is not I'm
so effing mad I don't even have words if
you need a seat belt extender you are
too fat to be on a plane buy two seats
or don't fly I said to the man hey we
can swap seats if you'd like to sit
together his sister is on my left he
says no that's okay
and then I started shrieking internally
now in photos taken secretly though not
revealing the other passengers faces you
can actually see that their bodies are
in fact
spilling over into her seat squeezing
her in on either side in fact they have
so much oversized baggage attached to
their physical frames that Watson can't
even put her tray table down there's
another photo for try to put the tray
table down and one of their stomachs is
like in the way and she can't put it
down this is very much like the scene in
Star Wars where Luke and Leia wind up in
a trash compactor that nearly crushes
them to death except in this case the
trash compactor is made out of sweaty
human flesh and thus is far more
horrifying also if memory serves me I
think C-3PO bailed them out of that jam
but Sydney Watson had no one to rescue
her not even after the fact when
American Airlines responded to her
complaints with this this was their
response their official company response
quote our passengers come in all
different sizes and shapes we're sorry
you were uncomfortable on your flight
period
of course if your luggage weighs one
pound over 50 American Airlines will
charge you a hundred extra dollars
if it weighs over a hundred pounds you
can't bring it on the flight at all so
luggage is not allowed to come in all
shapes and sizes but a passenger can
take up one and a half seats and the
poor sap who gets stuck with the half
seat
just has to deal with it apparently
this is the view of American Airlines
and of the American Media which as
mentioned blasted Watson for fat shaming
the bulbous individuals who nearly
suffocated her but as always the media
and the outrage mob have gotten this one
entirely wrong
it is perfectly reasonable and
appropriate
for Sydney Watson to complain about this
and and the reason why it's reasonable
is very simple
she paid for a seat on the airplane
she paid for the entire width of the
seat
she paid for the privilege of occupying
that assigned space and she paid a lot
of money even if it's a a crappy middle
seat she still paid a lot of money
because flying is not cheap
the obese people on either side of her
are taking space that does not belong to
them and that they did not pay for
so she is indeed the aggrieved party in
this case she is entirely in the right
in fact she is obviously self-evidently
in the right
it is absurd to expect a person to
simply be okay with having someone
else's body to people's bodies as it
happens wedged against theirs for
several hours in a row
you're flying on a plane not attending
an orgy
this kind of physical intimacy should
not be part of the bargain
it's only become a standard feature of
the air travel experience because for
one thing the airlines treat their
passengers like livestock and for
another
so many passengers these days in terms
of size are not far off from livestock
no offense it's an untenable situation
made all the worse when it's cloaked in
the language of body positivity
but really it's got nothing to do with
any of that
this all stems from a total lack of
concern for fairness for health
and for the comfort and well-being of
paying customers
and it's also a symptom of a of a common
problem in our culture
one that we talk about a lot on the show
where time and time again
we encounter a situation
where somebody has to be out of luck
right it's a zero-sum kind of contest
someone has to be inconvenienced someone
has to be made uncomfortable
someone has to be the loser in the
situation and when that happens we
always choose the wrong person to lose
we always give the Short Straw to the
exact person who should not be forced to
draw it
and we do this without even
acknowledging that we're doing it in the
case of air travel we can either require
that morbidly obese people pay for first
class or for multiple seats
or simply forbid them from buying
tickets at all if they can't fit into
one seat or or we can force normal size
customers to give up a third or half of
their seats and have their personal
space invaded
and be unable to use the features of the
plane they paid for and forced them to
be uncomfortable and miserable for their
the entirety of their flight
those are the two options it has to be
one or the other
the morbidly obese passenger creates a
situation where someone has to be the
loser someone has to come out on bottom
and someone has to be inconvenienced
and it's incredibly obvious that the the
someone in this case should be the
morbidly obese passenger who has created
the situation in the first place
but instead just as we do with boys who
want to access the girl's locker room
and with many other similar situations
we say that the person creating the
problem
should be exempt from its consequences
while innocent bystanders should be
forced to Bear the burden
it's completely backwards and ridiculous
that's the situation that's that's the
thing
when you when you are morbidly obese
and you get on an airplane
it you are creating a situation that
didn't exist before
and someone's going to have to suffer
the consequences unfortunately for that
now I say this even though I I do have
sympathy for morbidly obese people
I wouldn't want to be in that sort of
physical state myself
but the reality is that it's a physical
state you have to put yourself in
nobody who exerts even the mildest
effort to eat healthy and exercise will
end up 200 pounds overweight
okay it might be difficult to if you
want to stay in good shape especially as
you get older yeah that takes sacrifice
that's difficult
but to simply not be 200 pounds
overweight that takes very little effort
now if it's your choice to live that way
it's your choice to shoulder the
consequences
you can't demand that other people
shoulder it for you
and that is why Sydney Watson is not
canceled today but her critics in fact
are and that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]